To Have Kids or Not to Have Kids?
I'd guess that raising kids is one of the hardest jobs a person can do.
As a rough estimate,...
...I bet that 95% of mothers say it is a privilege to have children and watch them grow.
It is a lot of work but they say it's definitely worth it.
Some of them even say anybody who is married but has no children does not have a complete life,...
...because they never get to experience the joy and the sorrow that children bring.
But there are many couples who are reluctant to have kids.
They say that even though they want to have children, realistically it is difficult.
Even if the mother wants to stay at home to take care of the baby,...
...she might be forced to go back to work...
...because her husband's salary might not be enough to support the additional member of the family.
If the mother goes to work, she needs to find somebody who can watch the baby.
Either she would send the baby to a daycare center...
...or she might be lucky to have a close relative who would be willing to help her out.
But either way, it costs money.
So now, she and her husband have to work extra hard to pay for everything.
It is a vicious cycle.
Whether to have kids or not is an individual decision.
But one thing is clear...
...if more public support is provided for working mothers,...
...more women would be happy to have babies.